welcome to this video playing templar
assassin i think i need to briefly
adjust the recording area thump it's
better now and Templar assassin is an i
am from Russia right with 25 rating got
the advanced french yeah 97 and y'all
know I'm I need to be creative I don't
know I don't really know the exact
theory ok he's responding quickly maybe
hinge that this is actually underneath
ok I don't really want it to take so
let's put it on edge for ya if you watch
my videos you know that I have a
weakness for those kind of Queen sorties
Queen to h4 and stuff usually within the
e4 e5 openings why not do this here if
I've a saying and Paul is a born as a
pawn okay protected it I'd like to play
castles and and f6 if if possible the
play f6 immediately or f5 f5 and then h6
gene five if it takes pawn takes this is
really a massive position I come on
let's let's try that let's try that
threatening h6 and g5 or planning
threatening is made a bit much I think
you will take anyway but this will give
me a center and some interesting
possibilities even long castles some a
possible move and then e 5 really is a
big big center
yeah that's interesting you will in
tournament chess I had discarded the
French years ago and maybe if I would
have played it like like in this game I
would have had better results I never
had a problem with advanced french
really I always kept I kept losing with
the other lines okay but while thinking
that I have a good position I maybe
blundered is attacking d5 and attacking
wrong he's threatening to play this
coverage gets covered in a night
discovery who came and ok let's it's not
so bad I can play that and after Queen
takes I can castle long and Queen takes
I mean sir it's it's the principle move
now but also a dangerous one threatening
Bishop c7 mmm Bishop season while
threatening more even more but ok ok ok
let's not push up c7 Quincy five I also
i can just play for then winning a piece
ah ok the Queen hmm
mmm i'm pretty sure i should win
material yeah but i don't i don't see it
okay let's play nice i don't want to
spend even more time i'm probably just
the technical idiot I mean this isn't
bad for black not at all but i probably
had something substantial Bishop a6
could be a good move here Bishop a six
Wow
Bishop a 6 hmm it didn't he didn't he
didn't go for it probably a good one
good for me that he didn't play that ok
let's go back to this original idea
Quincy five I think I can just take and
then play G form as now Queen f6 doesn't
hang the look on h8 and also this Bishop
is pointing towards a to H to this might
be an interesting point not quite sure
what it means but ok the simple solution
is just Quincy five and to take
everything off on d6 and play you for I
mean this is not bad at the end of this
he has Bishop a six again now my king is
also vulnerable maybe a no is going for
that I understand derstand at least
three parts if I now take take him
he's not threatening something at the
moment ok let's take and once what
didn't what now mmm i take d6 he takes
him with a check take here
Queen age three and look G 1
let's let's let's think about this I
probably have a win here but I don't see
it if all makes the claim that's not the
win
I'm such technical idiot sometimes yeah
i don't i don't see the win and there's
one I'm very sure time morning yeah I
need to money to play a move ah that's
that's heartbreaking well rope 26 Queen
g5 maybe or something 25 Queen g6 this
f4 unfortunately
quit h stragglers look g one okay I
don't have time I mean anytime Brooks is
six no one's check yeah check yeah this
is just idiotic I lack resigned ah I
needed cause and tactics am just an
idiot this is so completely winning it's
really crazy I know absolutely
impossible that I'm not winning here
yeah it's minus four minus seven the
compass of course very ruthless rock g6
Luke g6 it's not that easy use it I mean
if you go through all halfway logical
moves you probably get to this at some
point but it's not so self-evident how
this is winning how is this winning for
instance queen age too ah when I had the
idea we judge to this is checkpoint
checkmate this is the point Luke g6
actually protects the night and it of
course threatens listen yeah yeah my
nephew if you look at it it's it's not
so difficult to see yeah I knew that
there was a win but I didn't see one is
there is there some other move that's
winning let's check I took mrs. probably
losing yeah that's losing is there some
other book takes is not as you can take
here I mean I know there's one win but
I'd like to check if there's another
yeah this also wins I didn't see a moose
after work g one
yeah that's also very easy this this and
resins Hanks hangs over yeah it is so
easy i'm just sometimes just blind
technically yeah i needed to play movie
i knew that this is bad but I didn't see
one of the good news i forgot about 27
that this is an idea I was only looking
at at some mates and I was also
considering this one blundering the
Queen took me some time to see that so
um yeah very disappointing not to win
this it was a very very risky play him
by white grabbing orders and I'd like to
check one thing he played the strange
with King edge one I thought that Bishop
a6 was interesting here you know they
are the best move especially seven and
the best move maybe the only one Quincy
success is a very very hard threat I can
even play here note that this check is
not working check winning the house care
up g6 I mean this is the strongest
smooth I thought also you could can
check here but that's just your t7 and
it doesn't help now I'm threatening this
mate Bishop e2 and then f5 attacking the
Queen Johnny shares what the help of a
computer would be really a really a
boring game you always watch would see
those some technical ideas alright bit
of a shame thanks for watching